un parfum d'été à magny les hameaux la
7e édition de remets tes tongs s'est
ouverte mardi 5 juillet des arts
l'estaminet vingtaine d'animations
gratuites et ouvertes aux petits et aux
grands jusqu'au 14 juillet cette année
la programmation tourne autour des
légumes
donc on trouve tout un tas d'ateliers on
a décliné le thème donc avec des
ateliers de musique sur légumes de
sculpture sur légumes des ateliers
jardin bricolage plantations on a aussi
tout un tas d'animations sportives
malles pleines découvert qui a toujours
dit nous
des nouveautés chaque agneau de mongolie
et si jamais les mêmes
non je trouve c'est simple c'est très
sympa de plus en plus il faut faire
profiter encore nos enfants des fruits
et légumes et leur faire partager le bon
goût à d
des fruits particulièrement dans cette
programmation 2016 végétarienne on
retrouve un stand de sculptures un peu
particulier ici les carottes les
poireaux les oranges et des pommes de
terre sont tranchées cisaillé entaillé
assemblée pour ressembler à des
personnages les cours sont
principalement destinés aux enfants sont
très créatifs en plus il suffit de leur
donner deux trois idées et leur montrer
comment on fait un oeil comme en fait
une aile
comment on fait des cheveux et après ils
le font tous les deux c'est partir
général après les parents soit une
dizaine en tout prix les légumes frigo
ce côté l'animation légumes devrait
attirer entre 300 et 400 personnes par
jour sont et les organisateurs un avant
goût d'été qui donnerait presque envie à
certains de rester cet été à manier
d'amour bah oui je prends la cause des
jeunes aubois ya du soleil